[Music]  it's okay buddy  hey it's okay don't you worry your good  friend Walter of course I'm disoriented  look at you I can't not look at you  Walter I can see my butt and your face  at the same time that is so cool fact  pigeons have 360 degree vision now  nobody has sneaked up behind you the fab  girl cool is so great pigeons can be  found in every major city around the  world and no one notices them it's the  most perfect form of spy could take  [Music]  let the beat drop I was the world's  greatest spy sleepy night night but then  you turn me into a pigeon you better  unburden eat right now you kind of bird  it yourself oh there's a bad guy who  needs to be stopped and now I have to  try to stop him while being a bird lucky  for you I'm your wingman  Wow  [Music]  let's get weird boom  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  we do  [Music]  all right Kimora starting it's about to  get messy time to go  I miss my hands  [Music]